on a parlé d'une jeune fille qui
s'appelle jacqueline j'ai envoyé 65
points sms à un mec
après avoir eu un premier rendez vous il
s'est dit rencontrer sur une application
vraiment que c'est ouf quand même 65 ans
au rancart de 500 par jour ça fait quoi
de plus vous vous êtes déjà fait un truc
que j'avais craqué sur une meuf dédia
les basij envoie du lourd
moi j'ai nagé c'est même ma première
amoureuse j'étais donc tout jeune et
j'ai pas supporté que on s'est engueulés
gg nager dans la mer jusqu'à me suis dit
lassé par le dauphin grand bleu chercher
on est venu me chercher en hélico et
tout ça a été fait parce que j'avais
j'allais me noyer quoi ou non mais
j'étais tellement mal à ma famille mais
je te kiffe pas tout ça on avait donc je
m'en bats les yeux tu sais nager frère
le gars c'est laure manaudou frère quoi
c'est vrai et donc à nager comme ça ma
vraie j'ai nagé je savais pas je me suis
dit chanter en même temps nabila ulama
beaucoup de choses en ce nombre de
messages
quoi c'est toi ça peut même arriver
bonjour c'est vrai sans son aval 65000
mais genre parfois 10 ou assez répondent
pas à 5 minutes à l'ôter ou
d'interrogation
ouais après plusieurs fins
d'interrogation d'état aurait donc
s'arrête pas aux normes direct
maintenant et toi à toi par vas-y à
pardonner plusieurs pensions
alimentaires
voilà d'où le nom de ma femme est tatoué
sur mon bras ouais bah j'espère qu'il a
prévenu que celle là c'est la bonne voie
selon et ben écoutez on le soigne et me
donne surtout voilà il anime
j'ai fait un enfant non alors et si
c'est vrai j'ai fait un enfant
fourmies j'ai tout quitté ennuis travail
appartement famille là il faudrait le
faire comme lui je suis parti comme ça
j'en ai j'ai suivi une femme c'est
pareil chez elle a fait la police non
non je l'épousé excusé je me retiens
c'est beau la première femme est alors
xiam je tiens à dire qu il est amoureux
zombies on a là par les horloges et mac
et les les îles et makelele eu vraiment
jean mi ça y est il a repris avec une ex
je vous donne les informations comme
elle que j'arrive vraiment ça veut dire
qu'il pourrait repartir éventuellement
ça rame la spéciale non là il est bien
qu'alain il est sage je reconnais la
personne je les aime beaucoup et
j'espère que s'il ya un mariage négocie
pas eh ben je vous aime beaucoup cette
série et bah écoutez ça me fait plaisir
j'espère que je serai témoin de quelque
chose ce soir si vous voulez fois baby
témoin de quoi je sais pas j'ai pas
comprises
[Applaudissements]
les uns parlent français
comment on est au niveau de la
compréhension sur youtube euros pour
vous voir ses bouquets j'espère que ça
va durer
on dit attention à l'été meurtrier
simard avec elle justement justement je
vais vous dire c'est très con excusez
moi oui les violations action un truc
comme quoi elle va chanter chez elle et
si on part ensemble et on reste que rien
mais je vous dis l'été les compliqué
parce que parfois on parle et et que sa
meuf on supporte pas gagné délire qui
passe pas il ya des bâches ou giuly non
mais c'est vrai c'est quoi je vous le
dis donc moi je ressens les vécus en
tout cas voilà je vous dis l'été c'est
le test pour les couples ah ah ouais
mais un sérum pas yahoo des couples qui
se font moi je vous le dis en septembre
ce que font aussi des charges a fait
appel comme ça je boude et où il ya des
charognards qui savent qu'il ya des
couples qui ont cassé avait en août
hélas à l'aéroport
[Applaudissements]
oui et là tu est temps qu'il montre à
l'attentât valise avec ton ex m'a fait
mal un charognard
car oui je vous le dis ça m'est arrivé
six journées du nicaragua envie d'en
parler moi un aller-retour pointe à
pitre paris après un billet d'avion 80
en 24 heures
oui bah ouais a lancé on s'est mariés
après non parce que tu fais l'aller
retour pour un tapis de paris tu voi
comme avec une autre 9 et tu reviens
frère dans leur auto au frère tu as une
aura sera toi que je crois nous sommes
jamais à l'abri savoir ça m'angoisse
déjà ce qu'ils aient eu
nous sommes en juin 1977 et jalada
terrasse sera 10 juin 1967 servir le
gars déjà on sait qu'il a sont deux
heures le gars ça c'est un truc 12e imam
race ratisser mon frère d'histoire
moulin prise en 1977 par le rideau tombe
sur l'année scolaire au collège blaise
pascal de villemoisson sur orge
je profite de ce spectacle de fin
d'année j'ai écrit un poème pour faire
une déclaration à christine que j'aime
et je n'arrive pas à lui parler mon
poème commence par christine oma divine
je commence à déclamer sa au spectacle
je suis tout fier de moi je vois qu elle
me regarde je me dis c'est bon enfin une
histoire d'amour ouais plus rien le soir
je vais l'avoir et je lui dis mais
christine c'était pour toi aimer mais
j'en ai rien à [ __ ] je n'ai même pas
compris que c'était pour toi c'est ça le
truc un peu fou nu et à oui elle a
déclaré gilles espèce de débile
tu sais
[Applaudissements]
miles vos questions vous avez fait moi
j'avais 13 ans après j'ai plus rien mais
j'avais 13 ans on était sur un pont à
ispagnac ans est un petit gars un jeune
garçon que j'aimais beaucoup joël madiba
situe même somme dans l'eau moi j'ai cru
qu'il y avait un grand trou dans l'eau
un vrai fonds est en fait pas du tout et
donc j'ai failli briser le bas du corps
a failli rentrer dans le onze
je suis tombé à l'eau et l'amour aussi
la vie c'est cet amour et donc non mais
c'est sympa de mettre un petit peu de
bonheur en début de semaine échappez
vous en avait réchappé après la guerre
bien sûr la guerre des santons la durée
qu'on maintenant derrière la guerre de
cent ans 1 206 613 513 vous me demandez
un médaillon qui a fait une licence
d'histoire
elle pense à la voiture elle paye à une
meuf 45 minutes du ve et avez quoi non
une semaine à bord à bord en surprises
ça va sinon il a mangé coup avant de
venir c'est le soldat il retombe pas
et là j'arrive au tienne il est
tranquille à s'échanger fac tu le
faisais ça nourrit de goethe
le gars est démonté de pistaches dans la
loi il a des renvois lutter pour un ring
je crois que c'est le pollen ouais c'est
ça alors d'abord entendons-nous sur la
définition de l'amour c'est quoi pour
vous l'amour semaine tranquille avec des
amis c'est bon oui qu'est ce qui se
passe au une vidange
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
comment sinon à quoi sinon parce que je
vois comme ça je me dis qu'est-ce qui
[Rires]
alors si oui alors l'amour cerib c'est
offrir quelque chose qu'on n'a pas à
quelqu'un qui n'en veut pas d'argent
c'est une salle de lacan et c'est très
important témoin par amour pour montrer
justement la complexité le paradoxe
amoureux
j'ai écrit un livre à l'homme que j'aime
et webo et boit l'eau et l'huile à lui
mail à lyon j'espère tenez je voulais
apporter d'ailleurs à mes joueurs à la
foule
[Applaudissements]
vous n'allez pas le garder vous allez
l'offrir un habitat qui est une grande
amoureuse et une grande passionnée bref
j'aimerais bien qu'elle dise oui mais il
est certains biens s'appelle splendour
ouais c'est splendeur mais en libanais
comme cvc écrit rambo normaux il ya des
trucs c'est vraiment je sais que si j'ai
bien compris comme j'ai beaucoup aimé
vos clips qui m'avait été offerte
d'ailleurs par marc cyrine invite à trop
de gens offrent le mien est beaucoup
alors j'ai voulu donner ou vous gardez
là je garde non pas parce que je voulais
lire un peu ah bon tu as un petit peu de
lecture est bien là les remercie
d'ailleurs je vous faire un résumé en
demo dans un instant very boffelli
alinghi mois par amour j'ai fait un
enfant à benhaim soit dit en passant la
guerre de cent ans et 116 113 c'est un
groupe de rap ça la voix
[Applaudissements]
en attendant j'embrasse rim k jerry sont
responsable c'est moi qui était le plus
près de chez vous c'est reeves et sinon
moi aussi mais je me suis fait tabasser
non mais tu me l'avais is a way ans un
bar avec un verre et c'est exactement ce
à quoi y'a un mec qui a cassé un verre
sur la tête mais en fait j'étais pas
avec la fim et la fille pour se
débarrasser d'un mec qui était un peu
lourdingue elle a dit je suis et ce mec
là il va péter un verre sur la tête et
voilà on va le retrouver on va se
défoncer et finalement on a été ensemble
non mais ça et vous êtes réconcilier que
le mec depuis au nom mais qu'il cassait
la version la tête je suis pas copain
copain